tengo cuatro candidatos y yo quiero ver
cuál de las siguientes operaciones con
fracciones es equivalente es exactamente
igual a menos dos tercios es decir yo
quiero llegar a menos dos tercios y
quiero saber cuál de las siguientes
operaciones con fracciones me dan en
efecto menos dos tercios así que te voy
a encargar que pausa es justo ahorita el
vídeo e intente resolverlo por ti mismo
intenta ver cuál de las siguientes
operaciones llegan a menos dos tercios
muy bien pues tenemos estas cuatro
operaciones qué te parece si trabajamos
con cada una de ellas para ver a qué
llegamos en la primera tengo un noveno
más cinco lo menos vamos a ver cuántos
novenos es un noveno más cinco lo menos
y bueno nosotros sabemos que si tenemos
el mismo denominador esto es lo mismo
que 15 entre 91 más 5 entre 9 porque
tenemos el mismo denominador y bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 1 + 5
lo cual es 66 entre 9 ahora si te das
cuenta tanto 6 como 9 tienen tercera por
lo tanto voy a dividir la parte de
arriba entre 3 y voy a dividir la parte
de abajo entre 3 de tal manera que esta
fracción no se va a alterar porque estoy
haciendo lo mismo tanto arriba como
abajo y bueno esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 6 entre 3 lo cual es 2 y abajo
me quedan 9 entre 3 lo cual es 3
dos tercios entonces un noveno más cinco
novenos es dos tercios pero yo quería
llegar a menos dos tercios aquí tengo la
versión positiva de dos tercios pero no
es lo mismo que menos dos tercios por lo
tanto en este momento puedo concluir que
no llegamos a la misma respuesta me hace
falta el menos en esta fracción y
entonces no llegamos a la misma
respuesta no estos no son iguales
ok intentemos ahora con estos que tengo
aquí y para eso voy a mover un poco la
pantalla déjame mover un poco la
pantalla hacia la derecha para que
trabajemos con esta operación que tengo
aquí y que me va a quedar déjame cambiar
al mismo color voy a utilizar este tengo
un menos un sexto más menos un medio y
bueno nosotros sabemos que esto lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera como
menos 1 entre 6 lo que hice fue pasar el
signo arriba para que no me estorben más
menos 1 entre 2 lo único que estoy
haciendo es pasar los signos arriba para
que yo pueda sumar estas dos fracciones
sumar este par de fracciones
y no tenemos el mismo denominador
entonces para escribir todo con el mismo
denominador
voy a buscar el mínimo común múltiplo
entre 6 y 2 y voy a buscar algún
múltiplo de 2 que también sea múltiplo
de 6 pero eso está muy fácil el 6 es
múltiplo de 6 y de 2 por lo tanto ambos
escribir todo en sextos y lo voy a poner
aquí esto es lo mismo ok que menos un
sexto ok que suman y ahora voy a
transformar a este menos un medio en
sextos y para eso voy a poner aquí el 6
y entonces creo que te des cuenta de lo
siguiente si este 2 lo pase para acá
como 6 para tener el mismo denominador
entonces lo multiplique por tres ok y
entonces tengo que hacer lo mismo con
este menos 1 este menos 1 para que no se
altere la fracción lo tengo que
multiplicar por 3 por 3 para que la
fracción siga siendo la misma y entonces
acá arriba me va a quedar menos 1 por 3
lo cual es menos 3 ok y ahora ya tenemos
el mismo denominador y por lo tanto
puedo decir que esto es exactamente lo
mismo voy a conservar mi denominador
y arriba me queda menos 1 más menos 3
pero menos 1 más menos 3 es lo mismo que
menos uno menos tres lo cual es
exactamente lo mismo que menos cuatro
menos cuatro entre seis ahora esta es
una fracción que se puede reducir por lo
tanto vamos a reducirla y para reducirlo
lo que voy a hacer es dividir tanto
arriba como abajo por 2 2 divide tanto
al menos 462 y entonces me va a quedar
que esto es exactamente lo mismo que
menos 4 entre 2 es menos 2 ok 6 entre 2
estrés y llegue a menos dos tercios y de
lujo es justo lo que yo quería quería a
ver si esta expresión menos un sexto más
menos un medio era lo mismo que menos
dos tercios y utilizando las operaciones
con fracciones llegué a que si en
efectos son iguales por lo tanto esta
fracción xi si es exactamente igual que
menos 2
de lujo pues ahora vamos a intentar
hacer lo mismo con esta y para esto
déjame regresar un poco a la pantalla
porque aquí ya me comí un signo debe ser
un poco la pantalla y voy a trabajar con
menos un tercio por menos dos y bueno lo
que yo sé y lo bueno es que esto lo
puedo ver de la siguiente manera como
menos 1 entre 3 que multiplica y este es
un número entero cuando yo tengo un
número entero lo puedo pasar a fracción
si yo divido a ese número entero entre 1
es decir menos 1 entre 3 x menos 2 entre
1 entre 1 para que siga siendo un número
entero y lo padre es que también ya sea
multiplicar fracciones por lo tanto esto
es exactamente lo mismo esto es
exactamente lo mismo y déjame cambiar de
color que menos 1 que multiplica que
multiplica a menos 2 lo voy a poner con
este color a menos 2 esto / dividido
entre 3 déjame cambiar a este color
entre 3 que multiplica a su vez que
multiplica a su vez
a uno y bueno sabemos que esto es
exactamente lo mismo esto es exactamente
lo mismo que menos por menos me da más
dos por uno es dos y abajo me queda tres
por uno lo cual es tres llegue a dos
tercios la versión positiva de menos dos
tercios y por lo tanto esta no es mi
respuesta correcta menos un tercio por
menos dos es dos tercios positivo lo
cual no es menos dos tercios y bueno
desde un principio podríamos llegar a
esa misma conclusión si nosotros nos
dábamos cuenta que esto es exactamente
lo mismo esto de aquí es exactamente lo
mismo que un tercio un tercio por dos
porque cuando yo tengo dos números
negativos multiplicándose habíamos visto
en el vídeo pasado que es exactamente lo
mismo que los dos números positivos
multiplicándose y bueno esto es lo mismo
que dos tercios por lo tanto no es la
respuesta que yo quiero y entonces vamos
a ver vamos a trabajar con nuestra
última opción esta de aquí para eso
déjame recorrer un poco la pantalla y
ahora tengo aquí menos un tercio entre
y medio y cuando yo tengo una fracción
que a su vez está dividida entre otra
fracción cuando tengo una división de
fracciones a lo puedo visualizar de la
siguiente manera esto es lo mismo que
menos uno menos uno entre tres es la
fracción de arriba y en lugar de dividir
entre la otra fracción voy a multiplicar
eso es muy importante lo hemos visto
muchas veces voy a multiplicar por el
inverso de un medio y el inverso de un
medio y déjame ponerlo con otro color si
este es uno ok y si la parte de abajo es
2 ok le voy a poner con este color el
inverso de un medio es exactamente lo
mismo que dos que 2 entre entre 1 entre
1 ok lo único que necesitamos hacer es
pasar el denominador el numerador y el
numerador al denominador y por lo tanto
dividir una fracción entre otra es
exactamente lo mismo que multiplicar la
fracción que está arriba
el inverso multiplicativo de la fracción
que es trabajo y bueno cuantos esto esto
antes que me cambien el color es
exactamente lo mismo por las propiedades
que hemos visto que menos 1 que menos 1
que multiplica que multiplica a 2 a este
2 que tenemos aquí a 2 esto dividido a
su vez esto dividido a su vez por la
multiplicación de los denominadores que
es 33 que multiplica que multiplica a
uno a uno
y bueno esto lo podemos hacer de una
manera muy fácil esto es exactamente lo
mismo que menos 1 por 2 lo cual es menos
2 - 2 - 1 por 2 es uno por 22 menos por
más menos entre 3 por una que es 3 y
bueno aquí llegué a menos dos tercios
que sabemos que es exactamente lo mismo
que menos dos entre tres dos tercios
negativo y ya están menos dos tercios es
lo mismo que menos dos tercios y por lo
tanto puedo concluir que esta expresión
que tenía aquí también es exactamente lo
mismo es equivalente que decir menos dos
tercios por lo tanto puedo poner en este
momento que ésta sí y ya acabe mi
problema es todo por este vídeo